you
it's a beautiful day to be alive uncle
Joey here I know I know you saying Joe
where the [__] you've been it's been
three days you don't spark with us hey
it's the holidays I gotta give everybody
a [__] break I'm not that interesting
you understand me you guys could smoke
on your own uncle Joey here it's a
beautiful day to be alive Saturday
November 26 I spot the store tonight
I got jujitsu I got some brightening you
know me dog my wife and the baby at the
zoo take it to the zoo retards like the
zoo what do you got to tell me that
floor rock anyway I don't never fear you
know I got a bowl ready [__] we got
some hardcore and we got some
[__] skywalk I got a
[__] ape [__] inside it's gonna
be a good weekend mother Fox what's
happening I've Sparkle buggin we'll talk
about Fidel Castro and what your
thoughts are on what you thinkin what
you feeling
but right now it's Refik time concept is
for some people it's whatever it's
reefer time
[Music]
oh is this [__] to kill Castro right
here my thoughts on Castro first war
doesn't really matter Mike my thoughts
on Castro I'm 53 years old
it wasn't meeting suffered or it was my
parents their grandparents those were
people really got to know Castro and
between you and I Castro was a [__]
piece of [__]
you know he lied to a lot of people a
lot of good [__] people solid people
but hey if it wasn't for Castro I
wouldn't be here dropping knowledge of
you [__] you understand me in my
book he's been dead for a [__] wild
they said he died at 10:25 but we didn't
get the news to like [__] at midnight or
something like that who the [__] knows I
listened Trump is president Fidel's dead
life moves on you just got a [__] man
and I said it's a piece of me that's sad
because my mom would have been happy my
stepdad would have been happy I was
old-school as man they [__] hate if
in doubt you could even bring them up
and [__]
don't buddy some way he's burning in
[__] hell listen he hated [__]
black people he hated gay people he
[__] had firing squads you know his
prisons were [__] outrageous I knew
what the [__] he wanted you to do you
know it son you really don't know until
you listen to somebody who's there I was
never there understand I didn't grow up
that way if you got caught wouldn't have
me got a year in jail [__] like that I
was never there I can't tell you what
that's about what I can tell you is a
beautiful [__] day to be alive
here in the straight States Black
Friday's gone that's what I give a [__]
you know me Amazon Prime [__] Next
Day Delivery I'm gonna stand on line
with beepers think you [__] people
and tackle be bump too old for that [__]
I didn't shoplift for the years and I'm
not going back
oh my little feels [__] great today
I'm Sam I'm sure you guys say turkey
sandwiches I don't want to see another
30 go [__] March I don't want to see
stuffing I don't want to see dick he
understand me
it's the Christmas season people it's a
very interesting it's like [__] 30
days or something the [__] Christmas
- I don't know I don't do the [__]
math I'm smoking weed [__] this is
it this is our time of year this is the
church is time to use when we do our
best is now every day - the 25th you
gotta make somebody's [__] day a
smile a tap on the back and I love here
people [__] dining out this time of
the year this is where we go to [__]
work okay
you cracked that stupid joke that just
brings a smile a sudden smile people
thinking about their relatives their
families there's a time healing we gotta
[__] work this is the time here
when reefer and laughter unnecessary
[__] you and your [__] gifts and [__]
you and your [__] trees and flop even
your Christmas genders - my friendship
being a friend to people who some people
just don't make the [__] holidays you
think I'm jumping up and down but I'm
sparking I got a beautiful family I got
my friends you know I make the best of
them
and that's it but we got to make
somebody's day every [__] day
something tremendous I love smoking dope
new people you make my [__] morning
understand me
I'm he's been overdue for a couple
[__] days Thanksgiving I had people
around all front of the day and it was
just tough to baby was following me like
an undercover [__] agent and that's
it and that's that but we're here today
that's all that [__] matters all
right ma'am you're not doing nothing me
Ari Eliza and Marc Maron's seven o'clock
the Comedy Store tonight got ahead by
nine and the next weekend Portland
[__] art and helium baby starts
December first my favorite [__] clubs
in the country that'll [__] around and
dad I put food trucks out get a couple
[__] gyros it's my favorite food
truck the Greeks
that will broke the shake I already have
my little almond milk smoothie and
that's it brother I slept good I feel
good you got arrested I'll take care of
all five [__] apples not yeah I can't
keep going that's what you don't know
when you're a young man you keep burning
that [__] thing away from the [__]
rear I take my time now everybody gets
happy I do a little riding a little
meditating and I spend time with you my
favorite [__] people on the planet
understand me the rest of these [__]
Gentiles don't know dick about dick you
people are halfway there but I it's time
for another boat and this is the [__] we
definitely kill Castro this is the
Skywalk oh my [__] god I'm just like
sugar
I say sugar I can't even describe it
it's like put your fingers and sugar
just just brute brutal [__] right I'm
talking shapes on a pacer better than
[__] Evan that's it [__]
it's Saturday the little amateur
Gentiles they're [__] jumping up and
down with the hats I knew you're already
platen you're weak you're making a movie
even you even plot into the beginning in
2017 today so you know it's over this is
the time remember man without a plan
it's not a man so there's the time you
make your plan are using a [__] bust
out in 2017 like the bad mother [__] of
the job I made time for me to get kicked
in the [__] head yeah trust me I was
there in a [__] top of a [__]
rocket ship in people's basements I was
dead get up read a book
wash your [__] push up through the
[__] vets and get a job and get it
together
removing [__] fast [__] you
know like moves fast but it's coming all
[__] knees I'm 200 and cocaine years
but I'm here cops up this sparking up of
my favorite people know or remember out
with you you're with me and they wanna
be with us stopped check yourself
that's it mr. tall about straightaway
behind
sit down that Mandela Fidel shot a lot
of [__] people who's another [__]
cocaine he made money off left open to
Colombians meanwhile his people [__]
stunned
[Music]
and that's it we stalled we're together
and we did it we made it to another
[__] day go outside look at the Sun
to say lord thank you for giving me
another day to sling [__]
major-league dick with my uncle Joey
you're right and that's it and that's
that people I love smoking reefer don't
you want me to tell you Oh
fishing is faster than listening I love
smoking reefer then you go fish then
it's a different [__] type of
fascination but to sit there with a
stick and wait now you gotta get stolen
or sit and think and open up have a
great Saturday make somebody's day
that's what Christmas is about make
somebody's day all right
stay black the church Monday morning
you'll have it ready to [__] rock
that's I'm rolling this week I love you
guys have a good day get stoned off you
later